I’ve seen a lot of women with earphones
to their bellies playing Mozart to make their
baby smarter.
But, it got me wondering, can a fetus in the
womb even hear anything?
Hi guys, Lissette here for Dnews.
In utero, a fetus' auditory system starts
forming at around the 18th week of pregnancy
and becomes functional at around the 25th
week.
At this point, the fetus is thought to be
able to perceive sound.
In fact, the period from 25 weeks of gestation
to 6 months of age is critical to auditory
development.
This is when the neurosensory system is trained
to perceive and differentiate sounds.
In other words, unlike your eyes, your ear
requires exposure to sound in order to fully
develop, so early exposure to sounds can be
beneficial.
But this doesn’t mean fetuses can hear in
the same way we do.
Because they are in their mother’s body
- sounds coming from the outside are somewhat
muffled.
High frequency sounds have trouble passing
through the mother’s abdominal walls, tissue
and fluids.
So, fetuses are more able to perceive lower
tones, and of course those that are louder.
Yet, despite this filter, many studies have
found that, that just days after they’re
born, babies can distinguish their mother’s
voice from other female voices, and even prefer
their mother’s native tongue.
But some Moms choose to add classical music
to this equation.
This trend is known as the “Mozart effect”
and has sparked a lucrative industry with
thousands of CDs being sold to parents with
the promise of making their babies smarter.
But, there is actually little evidence to
support this claim.
In fact, even the researcher behind the paper
that spurred the commercial madness has come
out and said that her findings were "grossly
misapplied and over-exaggerated."
However, there is some evidence that music
is better than random noise.
In fact, a 2013 study conducted by researchers
at the University of Helsinki found that babies
- who were played Twinkle Twinkle Little Star
(and other tunes) in utero - were able to
recognize the melody when they were tested
at 4 months old.
The researchers monitored the babies' brain
activation with an EEG while they played different
sounds, and those who'd been played the melody
in utero had higher levels of brain activation.
The researchers argue that “extensive prenatal
exposure to a melody induces neural representations
that last for several months”.The jury is
still out on whether this constitutes true
learning, but it’s clear that music influences
neural patterns.
What’s more, another study suggests that
prenatal exposure to music can impact neonatal
behavior.
In a clinical study of more than 250 infants,
researchers found that infants whose pregnant
mothers were exposed to music, scored higher
on 5 of the 7 areas of the Brazelton Neonatal
Behavioral Assessment Scale.
These babies performed significantly better
when tasked with following an object with
their eyes, responding to animate vs inanimate
objects and how quickly they recognized that
an object was familiar.
Those are a pretty big deal to babies.
So there is definitely some evidence to support
that early exposure to music helps with fetal
development, but more research is needed;
and no studies have conclusively found that
when babies are in the womb, Mozart is any
better than Bieber.